In science, it’s important to have quantifiable
data.
How bright is that star?
How strong is that force?
How smelly is that fart?
Hey everyone, Julian here for DNews.
I know it seems like a juvenile topic but
flatulence is a part of everyone’s lives,
and it actually can tell you some interesting
things about yourself.
So today, with as much maturity and aplomb
as I can muster, I’m gonna talk about booty
toots.
First of all it may surprise you to learn
that gut gas contains information about your
health.
For example: if you have lactose intolerance
it’s because your body no longer produces
an enzyme that breaks down the sugars in milk.
Your gut bacteria on the other hand love that
stuff, and will munch it up, leaving you uncomfortable
and passing the wind of Satan.
Or in rare cases those bacteria that are supposed
to be in your large intestine gets in your
small intestine and thrive, eating nutrients
that are supposed to go to you and making
you gassy and bloated in the process.
A bleeding ulcer will cause foul smelling
stool and flatus.
And an excess of hydrogen sulfide, the molecule
responsible for that rotten egg smell, may
be a sign of a damaged gut lining, inflammatory
bowel disease, or even in severe cases, colon
cancer.
So, if you have really rank stank, it can’t
hurt to see your doctor.
But even if you’re healthy, you probably
don’t fart daisies and rainbows, and that’s
because of that gut bacteria.
They munch on the undigested nutrients on
the way to your colon, but the odorous molecules
in their waste gas make up less than 1 percent
of a fart.
When you smell a fart, you're basically like
a shark detecting tiny amounts of blood in
water, except with farts.
Thanks, nature!
Many of the stench offenders are sulfur-based
and a prime source of sulfur in a diet is
from meat products.
There’s also skatole, which mammals produce
from tryptophan and it smells like… skat.
Though weirdly it’s also made by some flowers.
So roses don’t really smell like poo poo,
but some lilies do.
Vegetarians, that doesn’t mean your farts
don’t stink; sulfur is also found in broccoli,
cauliflower, brussel sprouts, cabbage, almonds
and dried fruit.
And while a vegetarian’s careless whispers
may be less odorous, they will likely be more
frequent due to a high-fiber diet that makes
gut bacteria thrive.
What isn’t made by bacteria is surprisingly
similar to air, which makes sense considering
you swallow air when you eat.
Typically farts are 59 percent nitrogen, 21
percent hydrogen, 9 percent carbon dioxide,
7 percent methane and 4 percent oxygen.
None of that actually smells; people tend
to think methane is the culprit because natural
gas leaks have a distinct smell…
Natural gas leaks in your home, I mean, that
one wasn’t a fart euphemism.
But methane is odorless, commercial natural
gas has an artificial smell added so you know
when not to light a match.
So if farts can actually tell you all this
useful stuff about your health, how do we
capture one and measure its composition?
According to Peter Gibson at Monash University
in Victoria, Australia, we can either measure
what your farts are made of by fermenting
poop, or capturing breath.
Because the gases in your gut get reabsorbed
into your blood and can wind up in your mouth.
That’s right, you all have fart breath.
On a less serious note, in 2009 Cornell University
seniors Robert Clain and Miguel Salas designed
a machine that was an unholy combination of
a thermometer, microphone, and hydrogen sulfide
detector.
When someone… *ahem* “tests” the device,
it combines information from the three sensors
to rate the sample on a scale of 0 to 9, 9
being what I can only presume is a perfect
fart.
It’s totally normal to pass gas, yet many
people are self conscious and hold it in.
But can that KILL YOU?
Nah, it can harm you in other ways though!
Tara has more here.
So, do you fart?
Keep in mind that if you say no, you are a
dirty dirty liar, pants on fire, and that
is dangerous because the methane and hydrogen
in your farts is flammable.
Let us know in the comments, subscribe for
more, and I’ll see you next time on DNews